good evening to you brett that call
between presidents biden and putin
happening late tomorrow from camp david
we're told that russia wanted to speak
on monday but the u.s pushed for that
call to happen tomorrow underscoring a
new sense of
urgency president biden stopping to take
a selfie on his way to camp david
but no moment for the press following
new warnings from the white house about
a looming russian invasion of ukraine it
prompted his emergency call with leaders
of canada france germany italy poland
romania the uk the european commission
and council and nato we encourage all
american citizens who remain in ukraine
to depart immediately
we want to be crystal clear on this
point
any american in ukraine should leave as
soon as possible and in any event in the
next 24 to 48 hours national security
adviser jake sullivan denied reports
putin has decided to attack and will
move forward next week but he confirmed
new concern putin could invade during
the olympics likely he said beginning
with aerial bombing and missile attacks
then a ground invasion cutting off roads
rails and air departures and the u.s
military would not be doing rescues
what scenarios would you put american
troops to rescue and get americans out
there's not that's a world war when
americans and russians start shooting at
one another we're in a very different
world than we've ever been in no worry
of wrongdoing at the white house did the
u.s wait too long to arm ukraine
especially with respect to weapons that
could defend against an airstrike like
you laid out did they wait too long to
move
u.s forces to nato countries and does
the president still view the idea of
pre-invasion sanctions as a stupid
question the united states has provided
more than half a billion dollars 650
million dollars in defensive assistance
to ukraine we have been forward leaning
and robust in defending and reassuring
our nato allies
time for deterrence is running out
including on capitol hill republicans
and democrats divided on the mother of
all sanctions bill and whether to impose
them before russia invades
i talked to a well-placed diplomatic
source a bit earlier about how the white
house can deny these reports that
continue to come out saying that putin
has decided to move forward with an
attack and my source told me quote there
are some worrying signals that could
lead you to believe a go order has been
given but it cannot be confirmed i would
be a bit cautious because the
information is imperfect and incomplete
white house correspondent jackie
heinrich live on the north lawn jackie
thanks